c'est l'heure du second débat de ce sens
public la COP 28 ouvre ses portes demain
à Dubaï parmi les nombreux défis qui
seront abordés nous avons choisi de
zoomer sur la fonte des pôles plus de
28000 tonnes de glace ont disparu depuis
1994 les conséquences sont nombreuses
pour le climat global de notre planète
pour les animaux évidemment qui vivent
dans dans ces régions mais aussi pour
ceux qui lorgnent sur ces nouvelles
routes commerciales en train de s'ouvrir
avant d'en débattre on fait le constat
de cette fond de la banquise avec Cécile
Sixou elle est allé rencontrer notamment
Matthieu torder un aventurier qui alerte
sur ce phénomène
voil anarctique sympa c'était un rêve de
gosse en 2018 Mathieu torderur part à
l'aventure
50 jours seul pour rallier le Pôle Sud
sans assistance et en totale autonomie
ah là là je suis seul au
monde il s'attend à des températures
glaciales jusqu'à à - 30° mais certains
jours il avance dans une neige molle en
T-shirt c'est complètement absurde il
fait beaucoup trop chaud là je comprends
pas cette météo 4 ans plus tard il
raconte son étonnement pendant plusieurs
semaines au début de mon expédition
c'est à ça que je me retrouve confronté
c'est-à-dire que parfois je tire mon
traîneau juste avec un une polaire quoi
un t-shirt polaire et ça m'a vachement
questionné quand je je me disais mais
ENF à quel moment dans ce continent qui
c'estêre le continent le plus froid du
monde et on peut se permettre de tirer
un traîneau juste en T-shirt des
questionnements et une prise de
conscience l'Antarctique change sa vie
Matthieu s'engage ses expéditions se
concentrent désormais sur les pôles et
les glaciers des montagnes à chaque fois
il observe de ses propres yeux la
réduction des banquises glaciers et
calottes polair et n'a désormais qu'une
ambition alerter sur cette fondte des
glaces et ses conséquences climatiques
mon activité aujourd'hui consiste à
faire le lien un petit peu entre la
communauté scientifique qui elle alerte
avec des rapports mais moi j'ai pas ce
bagage scientifique je peux juste
essayer de vulgariser ce qui se dit pour
le rendre intelligible auprès du grand
public et ça ça passe justement par des
expéditions par de la sensibilisation
par l'émotion par l'émerveillement par
des documentaires ambassadeur auprès du
grand public Mathieu espère aussi faire
bouger le monde politique il s'inquiète
notamment pour l'Artique ils font à
vitesse grandv et sera libre de glace en
je crois que on est tous au courant de
ce qui se passe mais finalement des
décisions très
courageuses à mon sens manque un petit
peu parce qu'on sait tous ce qu'il faut
faire il faut absolument arrêter tout
projet d'énergie fossile et et limiter
le plus possible les émissions de CO2 et
quand on regarde un petit peu la courbe
des émissions aujourd'hui qu'elle soit
nationale ou globale B on n pas commencé
vraiment à à ralentir quoi donc je crois
que c'est lent je crois que c'est
difficile je crois qu'il faut garder
espoir parce que tout n'est pas perdu
l'espoir c'est ce qui le fait avancer si
tout va bien Mathieu devrait retourner
cet été en Arctique pour une expédition
envoiliere au plus près des
glaciers quelles sont les conséquences
climatiques et géopolitiques de la fonte
des glaces polaires on est en débat avec
Françoise Vimeux bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes climatologue directrice de
recherche l'Institut de Recherche pour
le Développement Jean-Louis Étienne
bonsoir et bienvenue médecin explorateur
écrivain créateur de ce projet de
station océanographique polarp et vous
avez préfacé cet ouvrage Grand Nord un
voyage dans le cercle arctique publié
chez glena j'accueille Mika blujon Meret
bonsoironsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
chargé d'enseignement à scienceces PO et
à l'École de guerre sur la géopolitique
des pôles et des Outremers et vous
publiez les mondes polaires c'est au
presse universitaires de France Mathieu
croissandoau évidemment est resté à mes
côtés Françoise Vimeux cette cette fonte
des des glaces polaires est-ce que c'est
irréversible on est dans quelle
situation là alors oui la la fonte des
des calottes polaires et même des Glac
de haute montagne c'est irréversible à
l'échelle humaine he bien sûr parce que
on touche à des composantes qui ont un
temps de réponse très long et donc à
partir du moment où vous faites une
petite perturbation he de ces
composantes j'ai il y a aussi l'océan he
qui réagit très lentement et bien il y a
un temps de réponse qui va être de
plusieurs siècles voire de plusieurs
millénaires et donc la fonte là que l'on
voit la calotte du Grenland en
Antarctique et surtout aussi les
glaciers de haute montagne dont on parle
un peu moins et bien à notre échelle
c'est tir ver
ou Jean-Louis Étienne on peut faire un
peu de pédagogie pour pour commencer les
les glaces polaires c'est est-ce que
c'est la même chose en en Arctique ou en
Antarctique où vous allez aller avec
polarpod est-ce que on parle de banquis
dans les deux cas pardon c'est vraiment
une question de béoc je préfère qu'on
fasse un peu de pédagogie pour démarer
ou le Pôle Nord le Pôle Sud le Pôle Nord
est au milieu d'un océan un océan qui
est gelé qui gèle tous les hiver qui est
recouvert par de la banquise et tout
autour vous avez des terres des immenses
sibéries le le Canada hein et qui sont
recouverts d'une de de neige une grande
partie de l'année h donc ce territoire
est blanc hein il est blanc parce que la
l'océan est gelé avec de la glace
blanche qui réfléchit l' renement
solaire et tout autour le permafros le
jéiol le sol gel permanence et la
majorité du temps blanc et il réfléchit
le rement solaire aujourd'hui avec le
rayon avec le réchauffement euh euh
climatique vous avez la surface de la B
ise on le voit tous les ans septembre
septembre octobre qui régresse et qui
libère une zone foncée vous voyez il y a
plus de glace sur cet océan tout corps
foncé capte le rayonnement
électromagnétique du soleil vous faites
l'expérience pas pas maintenant parce
qu'il fait nuit vous mettez la main sur
une voiture blanche elle est à la
température ambiante la noire elle est
beaucoup plus chaude parce que le noir
capte donc on assiste on a on assiste un
article l'article est touché parce qu'il
change de couleur est-ce que c'est la
même chose l'utre côté alors ça c'est
l'Arctique l'Antarctique en terme de
surface c'est un peu la même chose
l'océan Arctique est grand est aussi
grand que le continent c'est un
continent qui est au sud d'un continent
de glace vous mettez un puzzle comme ça
28 Fran bien serré vous recouvrez le
tout de 2 km demi de glace en moyenne
c'est la taille du glaçon qui a en
Antarctique et ce continent antarctique
il est entouré par un océan qu'on
appelle l'océan Austral donc voyez c'est
l'inverse là-haut un océan entouré de
terre en bas un continent de glace Touré
d'océan h euh Mik mer on a un peu
répondu mais cette cette fonte accélérée
des glaces elle était prévisible voir
annoncée depuis depuis longtemps elle
était annoncée et justement elle a fait
l'objet d'un certain nombre de
controverses parce qu'il y a eu des
surexagérations par rapport à cette
fonte des glace on a dit par exemple
dans les à la fin des années 2000 que
l'Arctique allait être libre de glace
intégralement plus du tout de banquise
l'été dès 2012 puis dès 2014 puis dès
2016 et effectivement ça a généré deux
mouvements ça a généré un mouvement de
panique dans une certaine franche de la
population à l'échelle mondiale panique
et une un sentiment d'urgence pour
préserver l'épaule ok très bien mais ça
a aussi générer un sentiment
complètement contraire de gens qui petit
à petit ont bien vu en 2012 en 2014 en
2016 que l'Arctique en fait ne fondait
pas en tout cas toute l'année ets se
sont dit oh là là mais on nous raconte
vraiment n'importe quoi mais vraiment
ils exagèrent ces écol bobo et cetera
donc ce qui se passe à la fin du jeu
c'est qu'on se retrouve avec une
polarisation du jeu politique sur ces
questionsl et qu'à chaque fois l'ours
polaire la banquise l'Antarctique et
cetera sont instrumentalisé par les deux
camps et certains sont plus dans le camp
scientifique que d'autres très
clairement oui ça on peut ça on est bien
d'accord le phénomène il s'accélère le
taux de fonte des glaces a augmenté de
65 % en 30 ans François imimeux est-ce
que cette accélération elle elle elle va
d'une façon exponentielle c'estàd'est-ce
que ça s'accélère encore plus vite
depuis 4 5 ans par exemple oui alors ce
qu'on voit déjà on peut donner le taux
au 20e siècle la montée du niveau des
mers y c'éit 1,5 à 2 mm par an
aujourd'hui on est plutôt à 4,5 mm par
an donc c'est une accélération qu'on
avait pas forcément très bien vu venir
et anticiper et le facteur dominant qui
contrôle la montée du niveau des mers
aujourd'hui c'est la fonte des calottes
polaires et des glaciers de montagne
alors on ne sait pas forcément comment
ça va évoluer mais vu comment c'est
parti a priori oui ça va continuer à
s'accélérer et les projections
climatiques nous disent que sur les
trajectoires d'émission de gaz à effet
de ser sur lesquels nous sommes on aura
une élévation de l'ordre de 60 cm à la
fin du siècle de manière inéluctable on
aura plus de 1 m voire plusieurs mètres
dans les siècles à venir et là on ne
peut rien faire que s'adapter en fait et
et puis pour l'atténuation de du
changement climatique ça aura un impact
mais vraiment beaucoup plus tardivement
encore une fois ce sont les composantes
lentes de notre système climatique et ça
pose évidemment la la question des
réfugiés climatiques on y reviendra un
peu plus tard dans notre dans notre
débat les les températures constatées à
l'époque contemporaine dans certaines
parties du Groenland sont les plus
chaudes jamais enregistré au cours du
dernier millénaire c'est ce qui explique
ce professeur B moslo vinter co-auteur
d'une étude sur ce thème qui qui est
paru dans la revue natureer on l'écoute
on voit vraiment que ces endroits sur la
calotte glaciaire du Groenland se sont
beaucoup réchauffés en fait si l'on
replace ce phénomène dans le contexte du
climat on constate que les carottes de
glace remontent à environ 1000 ans et
qu'elles n'ont jamais été aussi chaudes
au cours des 1000 dernières
anné c'est donc la principale conclusion
de cette recherche le signal de
réchauffement planétaire que nous
observons partout dans le monde a
également trouver son chemin vers ces
endroits très éloignés de la calotte
glaciaire du
Groenland donc ça c'est pour le Pôle
Nord Groenland Jeanlou ettienne c'est de
l'autre côté on est bien d'accord c'est
au pôle Sud en Antarctique que vous
partez fin 2025 si tout va bien pour
étudier l'océan Austral pourquoi est-il
vital pour notre planète cet océan
austral l'océan Austral qui entoure le
continent Antarctique donc c'est le
principal puit de carbone océanique de
la planète à lui seul il absorbe
certainement 50 % du CO2 qui est
absemblé par l'ensemble de l'océan
mondial et donc il est loin il est
difficile d'accès on parle là des 50e
hurlant hein c'est c'est très venté les
marins du vent des globes nous en
parlent tous les 4 ans des vagues de 20
25 m c'est ça ça peut monter jus gr déjà
quand même quoi et les missions se font
essentiellement l'été et donc toutes les
communications sur cet océan se
terminent on a besoin de mesurer une
situe de longue durée en Nomo on a
besoin de s'installer sur cet océan dans
l'équation c'est quel type de vaisseau h
pour s'installer dans des bonnes
conditions de sécurité de confort sur
cette océan de tempête donc vous avez
imaginé un un vaisseau vertical c'est ça
bah oui il faut échapper à la surface
c'est là où le le le vent et la mer se
rencomre ça fait des vagues don les
bateaux sont posés à la surface donc ça
bouge si on veut échapper aux vagues il
faut avoir un vaisseau donc c'est un
flotteur vertical qui a 75 m de tir
Eneau donc il est pris dans des eaux
profondes stablebl à la surface on a un
trayit donc qui est pourux à la vague et
on habite dans une nacelle à une dizaine
de mètres au dessus de l'eau toutes les
maquettes qu'on a pu faire les études
montrent qu'il est très stable dans la
grosse mer ça va permettre de séjourner
et et faire des mesures tout au long de
l'année c'est ça qui est demandé oui
c'est c'est ça qui est important et
c'est ce que les scientifiques attendent
aussi c'est ça ah si vous voulez dans
les modèles climatiques c'est un je le
répète le principal P de carbone
océanique parce que le CO2 se dissou
beaucoup plus dans les eaux froides pour
ça qu'il est le principal le CO2 se
dissou beaucoup plus dans les eaux
froides que dans les eaux tempérées et
deuxièmement c'est un océan qui défire c
vagues sans arrêt en prisonne de l'air
donc c'est lui qui capte le plus de CO2
donc c'est un régulateur du climat
important François votre avis sur ce
comment on explique effectivement cette
régulation du climat par l'océan Austral
notamment alors en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que on a dans notre système
climatique deux régulateurs qui sont la
circulation atmosphérique et la
circulation tion océanique et bon
l'océan Austral a une superficie un très
large il a un rôle énorme dans la
circulation océanique et donc dans le
captage du dioxyde de carbone et puis
pour pour rajouter on a ce ce qu'on
aurait vraiment aussi envie de
comprendre c'est quelles sont les
interactions entre l'Océan austral et la
calotte antarctique on a beaucoup
d'incertitude sur comment cette calotte
polaire pourrait se déstabiliser au fur
à mesure que la température augmente il
y a des processus qu'on connait mal à
l'interface entre l'océan et les
plateformes glacées qui empêche la
calotte de glisser trop vite he si je
peux dire ça comme ça dans l'océan et là
on a vraiment aussi besoin de de
comprendre cette interface océan calot
temp ouis et puis alors puisqu'on parle
de fonte des glaces polaires c'est de
l'eau douce qui qui se diffuse dans un
océan salé avec quelle conséquence alors
c'est la raison pour laquelle ce qui se
passe au pôle ne reste pas auôlant
au-delà du du niveau marin quand vous
faites fond d'une calotte polaire c'est
le niveau marin partout sur la terre qui
augmente vous avez après un effet de la
fonte des calottes sur la circulation
océanique pourquoi parce que on met de
l'eau douce dans l'eau salée donc en
fait on change la densité de l'eau l'eau
de mer devient moins salée et en fait on
a une circulation océanique qu'on
appelle circulation thermoaline qui par
exemple dans l'océan Atlantique vient de
l'équateur se dirige vers le Groenland
avec l'objectif de répartir la chaleur
dans les océans arrivé au groenlande
cette eau elle se refroidit la banquise
se forme la banquise elle éjecte le sel
donc l'eau est froide et salée elle
plonge et puis elle repart en fait vers
des zones plus chaudes et l des
conséquences sur l'écosystème sur alors
non ça c'est un phénomène qui est
absolument naturel he cette circulation
à l'échelle planétaire en revanche avec
le changement climatique comme on ajoute
plus d'eau douce et bien on vient
ralentir cette circulation thermoaline
et donc là on vient modifier les
transports de chaleur dans notre système
climatique et là c'est vraiment des
perturbations à l'échelle globale allez
on va parler de la COP 28 avec vous
Mathieu souve demain à Dubaï on y
parlera aussi de la fonte des glaces
polaires elle est sous le feu des
critiques cette com oui alors rarement
une conférence des partie sur le
changement climatique puisque je crois
que c'est le nom complet Nura été autant
contesté avant même qu'elle ait commencé
alors pas sur le principe hein non même
si on peut se désoler que il se passe
plus grand-chose dans les cops depuis
celle de la COP 21 de Paris en 2015
n'insultons pas l'avenir peut-être
quelque chose sortira de ce conclave qui
accueille quand même 196 pays du monde
Vatican compris même si le pape François
on l'a pris qu' devait faire le
déplacement ne s'y rendra pas pour cause
de grippe non ce qui crispe en fait
c'est d'abord le lieu retenu pour
accueillir cette COP 28 à savoir Dubaï
l'une des
pétrroarchies qui a le pire bilan
carbone par habitant au monde et qui
tente ainsi de s'offrir à bon compte une
vaste opération de Green wasing en
direct sous toutes les caméras de de la
planète alors ça c'est pour le lieu il y
a aussi la personnalité choisie qui pour
présider cette cette COP bah oui le
sultan aljberer ministre de l'Industrie
et PDG d'adnoc le la principale
compagnie pétrolière du pays assise sur
les 4è réserves pétrolière mondial pour
le symbole c'est un peu comme si on
confiait au C Malboro la présidence de
la Ligue contre le cancer mais il y a
plus embêtant c'est que selon une
enquête de la BBC Ahmed aljber aurait
voulu utiliser son rôle dans cet
événement international pour conclure
des marchés dans les énergies fossiles
en juin dernier le gardien cette fois-ci
révélait que la compagnie pétrolière
adnooc avait pu avoir accès à des emails
relatifs aux négociations de la COP 28
avait même été consulté sur la stratégie
bref on en plein conflit d'intérêt on
peut même ajouter au conflit d'intérêt
le cabinetin plus grand cabinet de
conseil au monde qui se serait servi de
son influence dans les préparatif de la
COP 28 pour défendre les intérêts de ses
clients pétrogazier selon une enquête de
la FP donc bref c'est vraiment de quoi
irriter indigner nombre de participants
d'observateurs à commencé par les ONG
qui ont malgré tout décidé de ne pas
boycotter les travaux de cette COP
argant que les enjeux sont trop
importants pour pratiquer la politique
DESV et justement on conclut avec ces
grands dossiers qui sont là sur la table
dit 2023 l'année la plus chaude de la
planète et la COP 28 devrait être une
nouvelle occasion de réaffirmer les
engagements de la COP 21 celle de Paris
alors on peut dire que ça a l'air de
rien mais on se souvient qu'à la
dernière COP il a certains c'était
essayé à détricoter les engagements je
pense à l'Arabie Saoudite la Chine
notamment et puis on attend des
engagements aussi sur les énergies
renouvelables sur le charbon la
réduction des émissions liées aux
opérations pétrrogazières ou encore sur
l'hydrogène et puis la question du
captage de carbone et puis enfin dernier
sujet et pas des moindres la fameuse
solidarité nord- sudud dont le concept a
été déjà posé mais qui est encore loin
d'être financé ou et d'où l'importance
de ne pas pratiquer la politique de la
chaise vide effectivement Mik blujon
merid vous allez participer à cette COP
28 dans dans quel état d'esprit est-ce
que c'est un grand show de green washing
qu'on risque d'assister ou alors au
contraire nous profitons-en posons les
posons les enjeux faisons avancer les la
réponse est oui et non oui et non c'est
à la fois un jeu de green washing et à
la fois un jeu d'acteurs qui n'ont pas
le choix que justement essayer de passer
vers des énergies plus propres dans dans
mon portfolio de de de recherche il y a
la dimension hydrogène qui est très
importante et effectivement le sujet
qu'on voit par rapport à adnoc par
rapport au sultan aljber que vous avez
évoqué à l'instant même donc le ministre
de l'énergie des émirats Arab Unis qui
préside cette COP c'est que
fondamentalement dans le royaume et puis
au-delà de ça dans le golf il n'y a pas
de distinction entre la décision
politique et la décision business
c'est-à-dire que tout tout business est
politique toute politique est business
donc fondamentalement à partir de là
quand il a été fait le choix il y a déjà
plus d'un an et demi que cette
personnalité qui met mange à la fois une
position politique et une position
business dém sû que ah mais il y a pas
du tout de logique si on se place dans
la logique des des décideurs du golf en
général il n'y a pas du tout de logique
qu'il démissionne au contraire c'était
bien qu'il soit là parce qu'il
permettait à la fois de faire pousser
des sujets clima qui permettait
effectivement aux Émirats arabes unis de
se positionner comme un acteur du
changement dirons-nous tout en étant
évidemment un acteur des problèmes bien
bien évidemment et en même temps
développer du business parce
qu'effectivement pour les Émirats arabes
unis et c'est valable pour l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est valable pour pour la
Norvège c'est pour le Canada et plein
d'autres États encore et bien tout
simplement pour faire le switch pour
faire le changement des énergies
fossiles aux énergie renouvelable et à
l'hydrogène et aux batteries et bien il
faut pouvoir faire les deux à la fois
c'est comme ça qu'il voit les choses
Françoise Vimeux dans dans dans les jour
qui précède cette COP 28 on y est encore
on est à la veille on a essentiellement
parlé de cette polémique maintenant on
va pouvoir se concentrer sur les enjeux
c'est ce que vous espérez ah oui al
j'espère vraiment he parce que là il y a
vraiment un traitement médiatique avec
un angle sur la présidence de la de la
COP 28 il faudrait pas que ça éclipse
les enjeux fondamentaux alors pour moi
il il y en a trois euh vous l'avez dit
il y a d'abord le bilan mondial he de
l'accord de Paris où est-ce qu'on en est
est-ce que les pays ont tenu leurs
engagements est-ce que les engagements
sont à la hausse hein parce que dans le
fonctionnement des cops normalement
chaque année les pays doivent revoir
leurs engagements et proposer des
engagements plus ambitieux après il y a
tout ce qui est la sortie des énergies
fossiles donc là ça veut dire discuter
de la transition énergétique comment on
va faire d'un point de vue technique
comment on va l'organiser quelle va être
l'agenda ça inclut l'accompagnement euh
dans le développement décarboné des pays
du Sud hein cette transition énergétique
et puis dernier point moi qui me semble
important vous vous en avez parlé aussi
c'est la solidarité envers le sud à la
fois sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique et puis sur le financement de
ce qu'on appelle les pertes et dommages
c'est-à-dire les conséquences des
catastrophes climatiques qu'on peut
attribuer au changement climatiqu et je
voudrais juste rajouter un point le fait
que ça se passe au Moyen-Orient c'est
attendu parce que dans le principe de
fonctionnement des cops il y a une
rotation géographique la COP en 2012
avait eu lieu au Qatar euh et donc c'est
c'est normal qu'on tourne par grandes
régions du monde et le fait d'avoir une
COP euh dans un pays qui est plutôt un
modèle par exemple en terme d'écologie
c'est pas forcément un gage de succès on
se rappelle de la COP à Copenhague en
2009 où finalement il y avait pas eu
d'accord extraordinaire à la fin donc
moi je je moi je me dis voilà euh les
yeux sont rivés sur les Émirats arabes
unis je pense que c'est important pour
eux leur image et euh peut-être je suis
très naïve euh voilà mais j'espère quand
même j'attends beaucou et puis
malheureusement enfin c'est une réalité
jusqu'à pr du contraire on peut pas se
passer de des énergies fossiles pour
encore quelques années sur sur la
planète hein mais c'est le sujet c'est
l'opportunisme tout à fait des Émirats
arabes unis et d'autres États en fait le
le point qui va être clé on le voit déjà
depuis deux éditions de la COP là ça va
être la troisème fois on voit que
l'hydrogène est le sujet clé de ces COP
pour une raison simple c'est qui permet
ce sujet dehydrogène de ramener à la
table de négociations ceux qui veulent
développer les énergies renouvelables et
les États et les compagn aussi qui ont
intérêt à essayer de garder le plus
possible des énergies fossiles en
faisant évidemment ce changement vers
les renouvelables et donc
fondamentalement ce qu'on a vu c'est que
les négociations au niveau de la COP
auraient pu tout à fait complètement
partir en en cacahuète malheureusement
en 2021 et en 2022 et à chaque fois ce
sont ces acteurs-là Arabie Saoudite
Canada et évidemment Émirats arabes unis
qui ont dit non non mais attendez avec
l'hydrogène on va pouvoir rassembler
tout le monde autour de la table oua
c'est le cas aussi d'un groupe comme
Total qui fait encore une immense
majorité de son chiffre d'affaires sur
les énergies fossiles mais qui est aussi
un très très gros investisseur sur les
énergies renouvelables total qui fait
partie des partenaires de de polarp
évidemment ça vous avez eu des critiques
de toute façon dès qu'on dit total
énergie il y a des critiques pourquoi
vous avez accepté ou peut-être même
chercher ce
partenariat le principal P de carbone
océanique c'est l'océan Austral oui ça
fait 12 ans que je travaille sur ce
projet la première démarche ça a été de
dire il faut concerner les entreprises
qui émettent beaucoup de gaz carboné
faut quand même comprendre que c'est pas
total qui grille tout le fi qui va
chercher vous voyez ce que je veux dire
ce qui est important pour ces
entreprises c'est qu'ell modèent leurs
impacts dans leurs activités ça c'est
une chose il y a autre chose aussi pour
montrer la complexité du problème
revenons à l'Europe c'est c'est c'est
plus facile de réagir de comprendre
quand vous avez l'Allemagne par exemple
qui est revenue au charbon qui a qui
attendait beaucoup du Nordstream 2
malheureusement il est pas donc ils sont
revenus au charbon ils avaient
l'opportunité de garder 200 nucléaire
encore ils les ont fermés ils sont
restés au charbon la Chine marche à 60 %
au charbon l'Australie marche à 35 % au
charbon donc on parle des la polne aussi
la Pologne est très bien placé si vous
voulez donc une des premières à à
réduire considérablement c'est le
charbon c'est le premier émetteur si
vous voulez dans l'industrie voilà donc
quand on voit la difficulté qu'il y a
par exemple dans la discussion entre la
France et l'Allemagne où l'Allemagne ne
veut pas considérer que l'énergie
nucléaire comme une énergie carboné
parce que c'est des histoires de
business vous voyez bien que on est là
dans un milieu très diplomatique et très
économique effectivement moi je suis
d'accord avec vous j'ai l'espoir tout le
temps parce que si c'est si ces C
n'existait pas ça pourrait de plus en
plus dramatique quoi ce sont des balises
qu'il faut mettre régulièrement quoi
Mathieu moi je suis étonné que le
nucléaire fasse pas partie des grands
sujets de discussion forcément à la COP
alors il fait partie des sujets de
discussion et là pour le coup les
Émirats arabes unis essayent de pousser
le sujet du nucléaire aussi le problème
par rapport au nucléaire il est assez
simple ici c'est que tout le monde
c'està dire les États qui sont les plus
polluants aujourd'hui n'envisagent pas
du tout une électrification massive de
leur économie avec de grands réseaux de
grandes grilles électriques comme on
peut avoir en Europe on peut avoir en
France typiquement un pays comme les
États-Unis par exemple n'ont pas la
grille électrique que nous avons ici et
donc fondamentalement quand ils
imaginent le nucléaire c'est plutôt
aujourd'hui des nucléaires de petite
taille c'est des petits réacteurs
modulaires c'est du petit nucléaire pas
du gros comme on connaît chez nous allez
je reviens au thème principal de notre
débat la fonte des glass polais on va
parler de ces ces nouvelles routes
commerciales qui sont en train de naître
avec des projets d'exploitation et
cetera François je commence avec vous
est-ce que on a on a on a parlé du du
temps long et du fait que là on
finalement on subissait les conséquences
de de de décisions ou de modèles
économique très très ancien est-ce qu'il
y a un un risque là aussi de CERC
vicieux c'estàdire que plus on
va exploiter ces région qui ne l'était
pas plus on risque d'aggraver la
situation ou pas d'ailleurs oui alors
bon il y a plusieurs choses d'abord
d'abord quand on parle des des nouvelles
routes he ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
les les dernières études elles nous
montrent que on s'attend à partir de de
2030 2050 donc c'est large à avoir à
voir plutôt des mois de septembre où on
a pas de banquise au niveau de l'Artique
pas de banquise ça veut dire moins de 1
million de de kilomètr carrés hein dans
dans le langage scientifique donc ça
permettrait effectivement d'ouvrir des
routes maritimes pour le
transport moi je à mon avis hein c'est
c'est ce qui a été dit le problème c'est
pas tant d'ouvert d'ouvrir les routes
maritimes c'est que quand on enlève de
la surface blanche pour de la la
remplacer par de la surface sombre et
bien on a une absorption plus forte de
l'énergie solaire donc en fait on
amplifie le réchauffement localement
c'est pour ça que l'AR ou c'est pas
parce qu'on utilise ces routes
maritimes situation AC la connaissance
que j'ai voilà en tout cas avec la
connaissance que j'ai je n'en ai pas
l'impression après s'il y a un flux
énorme de pagbo on va peut-être avoir
des problèmes de pollution
atmosphérrique
ouiseslep
desacig rebelotte on a le même problème
qu'on appelle le problème d'albéo ou mon
mer qui est intéressé par ces nouvelles
routes commerciales j'imagine qu'il a
beaucoup de monde prêt à investir ou qui
ont déjà investi tout le monde tout le
monde tout le monde c'està-dire que
évidemment il y a les h états de
l'Arctique même pas tous les énuméré
mais évidemment c'est pour la plupart
des pays qui sont alliés de la France
évidemment plus la Russie on a de
l'autre côté un certain nombre de pays
qui sont pas dans cette zone arctique
mais qui ont des intérêts économiques
que ce soit sur le volet énergie et là
on a les énergie fossile on a aussi les
renouvelables l'hydrogène que ce soit
sur le secteur minier comme par exemple
pour alimenter le secteur de la batterie
évidemment et de la transition
énergétique mais quand vous dites ça ça
veut dire quoi on pourrait exploiter des
mines là où on ne le faisait pasant on
pourrait c'est on fait c'est-à-dire que
c'est déjà une réalité en fait quand il
y a il y a 10 15 ans on parlait de
projets en Arctique tout simplement des
projets aujourd'hui ils sont sont tout à
fait concrets et si je me si je reviens
un petit peu même en arrière ça fait
déjà plus de 100 ans qu'on exploite du
pétrole et du gaz en Arctique ça fait
déjà plus de 150 ans qu'on exploite du
charbon en Arctique ça fait 500 ans
qu'on exploite les ressources marines de
l'Arctique c'est pas nouveau du tout ce
qui est nouveau par contre c'est la
magnitude à laquelle on exploite
aujourd'hui quand on imagine développer
des giga projets qui existent
aujourd'hui déjà dans l'Arctique russe
dans l'Arctique norvégien dans
l'Arctique américain de pétrole de gaz
de fait ces projetslà sont directement
polluants et vous me permettez juste une
phrase en France évidemment on a
beaucoup parlé de l'interdiction de
l'arrêt de l'importation du gaz russe
suite à la guerre en Ukraine
fondamentalement aujourd'hui en 2022 et
en 2023 on importe en France toujours du
gaz naturel liqufié de Russie et il y a
qu'un seul endroit où on le fait en
Russie c'est en Arctique ouais il y a
pas de sanctuarisation jean-loutien non
il faut comprendre quand on parle de
l'exploitation de ces routes que vous
avez soulevé bien sûr la banquise fond
mais ell font essentiellement à la fin
de l'été on le voit mais tous les hivers
ça regèle ouais donc ce n'est et elle
fait aujourd'hui elle faisait dans les
années 80 elle faisait 1,80 2 m
d'épaisseur aujourd'hui ce qui disparaît
c'est la vie la glace
pluriannuelle voyez parce qu'elle
disparaiss là et c'est de la jeune glace
qui arrive qui fait 80 cm 12 200 mais
c'est c'est quand même un obstacle à la
navigation il n'y a pas de compagnie
aujourd'hui standard qui investissent
dans des brises glace il y en a très peu
ce qui devient intéressant et les
Chinois s'en sont aperçus les Chinois
attendent que le le ce que vous disiez
c'est que le Pôle Nord ne soit plus
englacé c'est-à-dire que la route ne
sera plus le nord-est ni le nord-ouest
ça sera direct being pôle Nord Islande
et là les Chinois ont investi ils
veulent acheter effectivement de quoi
faire à Islande un port de Port de
conteneur ça sera tout droit ils ont
déjà commencé à travailler sur leur
brise glace c'est cette route directe
ilils cherchent à faire pour économiser
parce que nord-est vous dépendez des
rues c'est compliqué nord-ouest il y a
encore des clés de passage difficile à
faire oui est-ce qu'on peut juste
rappeler au téléspectateurs et à
moi-même à qui appartient l'Arctique et
à qui appartient l'Antarctique Mik Bjon
bien j'y vais j'y vais merci j'adore les
questions pédagogues alors les huit
États qui qui détiennent donc l'Arctique
on a SEP États qui sont bien connus les
États-Unis le Canada les États-Unis
l'Alaska faut pas oublier l'Alaska c'est
comme ça qu'ils sont effectivement en
Arctique le Canada donc le Danemark avec
le Groenland qui est un outrem donc du
Danemark l'Islande bien sûr la Norvège
la Suède la Finlande ça c'est les SEP
états qu'on pourrait qualifier
d'occidentaux puis vous avez la Russie
qui représente 53 % de la côte de cet
Océan Arctique donc ces territoires là
c'est chez eux et donc ces territoires
là ces populations là ces décideurs
politiques là ne veulent pas que des
populations ou des politiciens comme des
Français des Chinois et autres viennent
leur dire quoi faire ça c'est la
première difficulté donc non ça peut pas
être sanctuarisé de cette manière-là
ensuite pour ce qui est de l'Antarctique
la situation est différente dans le sens
où vous avez SEP état dont la France qui
ont émis des revendications
territoriales avant la signature du
Traité sur l'Antarctique qui date de
1959 et ce Traité sur l'Antarctique il
dit quoi il dit et c'est la même chose
pour la lune ou pour l'espace par
exemple que les revendications
territoriales sont gelé mais pour autant
on n'empêche pas les pays qui ont émis
ces revendications territoriales comme
la France l'Argentine le Royaume-Uni
d'administrer ces territoire comme si
c'était les leurs c'est comme ça que en
France typiquement en teradellis on a
des représentants du gouvernement qui
portent l'écharpe on a des levés du
drapeau et cetera et cetera c'est la
France en tout cas pour la France alors
je voudrais qu'on parle des réfugiés
climatiqu avec ces ces ces chiffres
donnés par Oxfam qui parle de 260
millions de réfugiés climatiques en 2030
1,2 milliards en 2050 peut-être qu'ils
sont à prendre avec des pincettes ces
chiffres je veux bien vous entendre
là-dessus mais François zimeux on peut
déjà dire que des réfugiés climatiques
il y en a déjà on a eu il y a quelques
jours l'Australie qui a annoncé
accueillir des les habitants d'un d'un
archipel du Pacifique c'est ça oui alors
en fait aujourd'hui il y a euh des
réfugiés climatiques mais des si on
parle en terme de migration c'est des
migrations qui restent très locales qui
reste régional euh la plupart du temps
parce que les gens ne savent pas où
aller pourquoi parce que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui les grandes catastrophes euh
avait des impacts sur des pays
particulièrement vulnérables et donc des
pays pauvres et voilà les gens restent
malheureusement sur des ruines euh pour
ce qui est euh de de l'avenir là les
chiffres que vous donnez sont vrais par
exemple on sait que d'ici à 2050 on a 1
milliard de personnes qui vont être
touché par l'élévation du niveau marin
ça concerne évidemment les États
insulaires où certains États ne vont
plus être habitabl hein vraiment la
question l'habitabilité est poséeou mais
230 260 millions en 2030 2030 c'est là
c'est ah oui non mais c'est moi je suis
ça concerne qu je suis pas étonné ça
concerne quel pays ça peut concerner
bangladesch par exemple ça peut
concerner la c'est tous les pays
vulnérables tous les pays qui ont un
littoral particulièrement vulnérable à
la fois évion du niveau des mers aux
submersion marine et à l'érosion qui est
un phénomène naturel amplifié par le
changement clim paronê francofis et les
sécheresses oui et pardon
franco-français il y a des terres
françaises concernées aussi voilà ça
concerne aussi nos outr mères ça
concerne évidemment certains certains
Hol polynésien ça concerne aussi
Saint-Pierre et miklon puisqu'on a vu
l'isme entre Saint-Pierre entre pardon
mlon et Langlade être attaqué de plus en
plus par les flots provoquant donc une
rupture de de de du lisme potentiel à à
moyen long terme donc fondamamentalement
oui ça nous touche déjà au-delà de la
France continentale allez on va parler
des conséquences aussi en terme de
biodiversité je propose à Audrey vetas
de nous
rejoindre rebonsoir Audrey on va on va
parler de du manchau empereur qui
pourrait être la première espèce polaire
à disparaître d'ici la fin du siècle
c'est une espèce que le grand public a
appris à connaître avec un succès au
boxofice la Marche de l'Empereur bien
évidemment qui suit le périple de la
reproduction de cette espèce qui vit en
Antarctique alors je parle de périple
parce que les adultes font en général
des kilomètres pour atteindre la zone de
reproduction les femelles pondent
ensuite un seul œuf elles le laissent au
mal et elles partent chercher de la
nourriture c'est donc le mâle qui garde
l'œuf au chaud et sans bouger et sans
manger un rituel qui n'a lieu que
l'hiver les manchaux empereur sont
menacés par le changement climatique ils
se reproduisent pendant l'hiver en
Antarctique la pompe des ufs se fait à
la fin de l'automne l'éclosion a lieu
pendant l'ER
et les parents les nourrissent jusqu'à
ce qu'ils prennent leur envol au
printemps alors pour que les petits
soient autonomes il faut que leur plumes
deviennent interméable la période qui
précède est donc extrêmement sensible
d'autant qu'on parle de température qui
peuvent descendre jusqu'à - 45°gr je
parle sous haute contrôle le problème
c'est que l'EN dernier en plein milieu
de cette période charnière la fonte de
la banquis s'est accéléré c'est ce que
je vais vous montrer c'est des images
satellites là nous sommes le 10 octobre
et ce que vous voyez en noir et bien
c'est l'une des colonies qui est
observée par le British Antarctique
Antarctique pardon surve et là vous
voyez 18 jours plus tard la fonte est
dramatique la colonie est emportée et la
totalité des poussins euh est morte
noyée ou de froid parce que la glace s s
brisé pardon sous leurs pattes et ils
n'était pas assez mature pour affronter
ces conditions c'est malheureusement ce
qui s'est passé pour quatre des cinq
colonies qui étaient observé c'est le
premier échec majeur de reproduction des
manchau empereur qui est dû au
réchauffement climatique les chercheurs
le prévoyait depuis un certain temps
c'est la première fois que ça se passe
et que ça se passe sous nos yeux et que
c'est documenté est-ce que ça pourrait
se répéter oui parce qu'en fait les
manchau empereur se reproduisent tout le
temps tous les ans au même endroit le
lieu de reproduction est donc mis en
péril et d'après les chercheurs ils
peuvent s'adapter mais ça n'ira jamais
aussi vite que le réchauffement
climatique si rien ne change l'espèce
pourrait disparaître d'ici la fin du
siècle Thomas merci Audrey de ces
explications Jean-Lou Etienne votre
expédition polarp polarpe pardon elle va
aussi permettre d'étudier la faune
marine dans cet océan austral oui parce
que le le polarpod est un naire
silencieux h le moteur de propulsion
c'est le courant circouolaire l'énergie
en a si éoliennne qui nous donne de
l'autonomie et donc sur ce sur cette
plateforme on va installer des des
hydrophone des micros sous l'eau et par
une écoute passive on va faire un
inventaire de la faone parce qu'on
connaît la signature sonore de
pratiquement toutes les espèces sauf des
manchas qu'on ignore un peu mais d'une
manière générale cette écoute pas
permanente on va faire deux fois le tour
ça devrait durer 3 ans donc par une
écoute permanente on va avoir une idée
assez assez claire l'Antarctique si vous
voulez c'est un immense désert de glace
la vie elle elle est à la périphérie à
la frontière entre l'eau et la glace où
les espèces viennent là pour se
reproduire et repartent en mer et
d'après on sait pas très bien où elles
vont donc le fait de faire un inventaire
comme ça par acoustique d'avoir une idée
un peu de la migration de ces espèces
une fois qu'elles ont quitté le lieu de
ndification ou de naissance François
c'est tout un système qui qui souffr
avec la fondte de glaces polair oui bien
sûr c'est tous les les écosystèmes qui
sont à la fois les écosystèmes marins
donc les écosystèmes sur le le le
littoral et puis tous les écosystèmes
qui visent qui vivent pardon à
l'interface banquise et puis océan mais
il y a bien sûr les écosystèmes mais moi
je pense en article aussi aux sociétés
humaines parce que le changement
climatique affecte leur mode de vie leur
leur nourriture leur patrimoine et il y
a quand même 4 millions he de personnes
qui vivent dans la la région arctique et
quand on sait que ça se réchauffe trois
à quatre fois plus vite hein que la
moyenne mondiale ça vous donne une idée
de la manière dont ils sont impactés
mikjour et pour autant si vous allez au
Groenland par exemple vous allez avoir
effectivement une franche de la
population plutôt jeune plutôt éduqué
urbanisé dans la seule ville la capitale
du Groenland n hook qui va vous dire
effectivement voilà c'est un danger
c'est vrai et puis vous allez avoir tout
un panel de de votants au Groenland
plutôt dans les les p pphérie qui vont
vous dire au contraire ah mais non mais
c'est génial le réchauffement climatique
parce que de fait ça nous permet de
développer de nouveaux business
typiquement le renouvelable et
l'hydrogène typiquement vendre de l'eau
typiquement vendre du sable pour le
ciment par exemple en Chine ça permet de
faire remonter les poissons puisque les
poissons évidemment remontent bien sûr
vers le nord et donc d'avoir des
poissons qui ont une plus grande valeur
ajoutée à pêcher donc le secteur de la
pêche trouve un intérêt et au Grenland
on va trouver donc cette polarisation
politique
entre le parti INITE Attac it et je vous
je vous ai pas je vous éparne le reste
et d'autres parties comme chumut où on
va retrouver justement cette dichotomie
entre est-ce qu'il faut être juste des
victimes du réchauffement climatique ou
est-ce qu'il faut pas l'embrasser et en
en tirer les bénéfices je trouve que ce
débat qu'on a au Groenland il est à
mettre en regard avec le débat qu'on a
eu tout à l'heure sur la question de des
Émirats arabes unis de la même manière
dernière conséquence de la fond des
glaces dont je voudrais parler avec vous
concerne les les virus elle a été
évoquée par Emmanuel Macron c'était lors
de l'ouver ouverture du sommet des pôles
palarsemite à Paris on écoute ce
phénomène dont l'effet le plus immédiat
et le plus visible est la fonte des
glaces représente à l'échelle de
l'humanité un défi inédit qui était
évidemment climatique de biodiversité
mais aussi civilisationnelle l'élévation
du niveau de la mer qui submergera de
nombreux littoraux la raréfaction de
l'eau potable les migrations climatique
la libération du CO2 voire de nouveaux
risques pandémiques avec la fonte du
permafrost toutes ces menaces sont déjà
bien
réelles car elles sont pour beaucoup la
résultante d'émission de CO2 déjà libéré
par le passé et qui produiront leurs
effets dans les prochaines décennies je
voudrais qu'on parle de ces de ces virus
nouveau risques pandémiqu avec la fonte
du permafros jean-louistienne dans cette
émission Mathieu peut en témoigner on
essaie de pas être inutilement anxiogène
mais bon de quoi on parle là parle de
virus enfoui endormi depuis ça le
permafost et qui émerge aujourd'hui et
contre lesquels nous n'avons pas de
système de de de défense juste un
exemplaire un exemple quand tu avais
traversé l'Antarctique pendant ça durait
7 mois pendant 6 mois on avait rien puis
à un au bout de 6 mois il y a un petit
avion qui est venu amener la nourriture
pour les chiens qui nous manquaient il y
en a deux le japonais et le chinois sont
montés à bord pour 2 jours après ils
avaient la
grippe tout pour dire c'est qu'on est
vivait dans un univers complètement
stérile et tout d'un coup la rencontre
avec deux personnes fait qu'ils ont
chopé la griipe tous les deux vous savez
dans notre corps on a plus de bactéries
et de virus que de cellules quoi h donc
il y effectivement partout on est plus
ou moins immunisé et là émerge avec la
fonte du permafrost sol gelé en
permanence des vieux virus est-ce qu'il
faut forcément en avoir peur ben écoutez
il faut les étudier et voir comment on
peut faire face quoi mais on a des je
crois que peur non il y a il y a un
optimisme obligatoire si vous voulez
parce que tu l'as évoqué on a on a
conscience de la situation et on a une
intelligence pour les solutions c'est ça
qu'il faut essayer de mettre en œuvre
quoi ça demande des investissements ou M
c'est une c'est une problématique qui
est connue depuis longtemps dans le sens
où au niveau du Conseil de l'Arctique
qui est l'organe diplomatique de
référence dans la région donc on est
retourner dans le Grand Nord là au
niveau du Conseil de l'Arctique il y a
un réseau de détection des risques des
virus mal ou non connus euh qui pourrait
réémerger du permafrost qui existe
depuis
1998 donc il y a déjà une coopération
internationale régionale qui existe par
rapport à ce risque-là il n'est pas
nouveau mais c'est bien que des pays
comme la France ou les Émirats arabes
unis qui en ont pas parl aussi récemment
quand ils ont essayé d'organiser le
sommet diplomatique du trème pôle pour
parler de l'Arctique de l'Antarctique et
de l'Himalaya petit à petit que ces
états qui sont pas du tout en Arctique
prennent conscience que ça peut les
toucher aussi François hum on a on a
quasiment pas parlé de de NS glaciers
qui eux aussi sont sont menacés est-ce
que cette problématique est la même dans
des glaciers c'est est-ce qu'il y a des
virus en fruit qui pourrai ressortir oui
alors bon moi je fantasme pas trop sur
les virus au niveau du du permafrost je
suis plus inquiète des dégagements de de
gaz à effet de à la fois méthane et puis
dioxyde de carbone qui pourrait être
créé par l'activité de bactéries hein
qui se remettrait à finalement dissoudre
la matière organique qui est dégelé
permafrost en
dégelant2ouou al du méthane et puis du
méthane et puis les et les les bactéries
en fait qui sont comme vous libérez
finalement le sol n'est plus gelé hein
vous allez avoir de la végétation de la
matière organique donc les bactéries en
fait vont la dégrader et on va avoir des
émissions de de gaz à effet donc je suis
plus inquiète là-dessus après pour
revenir à nos glaciers je suis pas très
inquiète des des virus en revanche ils
vont disparaître on sait que d'ici 10 à
15 ans dans les Pyrénées nous n'aurons
plus de glaciers même sort dans les
Alpes pour les glaciers qui sont à moins
de 4000 m d'altitude et au-delà de 4000
m on aura une surface glaciaire qui
restera 5 à 20 % de ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui donc il faut vraiment se
rendre compte que ce sont les premières
victimes pour le coup chez nous de ce
réchauffement climatique et donc des
paysages qui vont être complètement
modifiés j'allais dire heureusement en
France on est on ne fait pas partie des
régions qui
dépendent énormément du ruissellement
des glaciers quoique le débit de nos
rivières en été en dépend et donc les
écosystèmes niveau des des cours d'eau
va va monter alors quand ça fond mais
quand vous n'en avez plus ça il y en a
plus et ça c'est un vrai problème par
exemple en Asie central ou dans les
zendes sud-américaines ou pendant la
saison sèche finalement les glaciers
sont une ressource en eau il faut
rappeler que je crois que c'est 2/3 de
l'irrigation mondiale ind dépend du
ruissellement des glaciers donc tant que
ça coule et que ça fond bah vous êtes
heureux qui quand il y a plus de glacier
ça devient difficile bon et la France a
obtenu enfin c'est quasiment sûr les
l'organisation des Jeux d'Hiv 2030 ça
fait partie des infos c'est pas sur
quelle neige far positif ça va c'est une
très bonne nouvelle pour pour la France
un dernier mot sur le le le permafrost
amica blujon Mered est-ce qu'il y a là
aussi le fait que il fondent pardon moi
je suis un peu basique je suis beaucoup
moins pointu que vous mais est-ce que ça
facilite des exploitations minièires ou
alors pas du tout ça n'a rien à voir ah
alors je vais vous dire oui et non ça
facilite certaines certaines choses dans
le sens où effectivement ça peut en
théorie donner accès à des zones qui
étaient PL plutôt difficiles d'accès
jusqu'à maintenant mais en réalité si le
sol qui est sous votre usine par exemple
de gaz naturel liqufié est trop meuble
bah de fait ça va avoir un impact sur
vos infrastructures et on l'a vu ça a
généré des fuites ça a généré des
pollutions majeures et cetera c'est la
raison pour laquelle typiquement sur un
grand projet comme celui de Yamal LNG
donc dans la péninsule du Yamal dans
l'Arctique russe un projet notamment
porté par Total mais c'est pas les seuls
ce qu'ils ont décidé de faire c'est de
mettre 60000 puit pardon 60000 pieux
dans le permafrost sous l'usine ces
pieux vont être au niveau de la surface
de chaque pieux à une température de -
4° celus de manière que au contact entre
le pieu et le permafhrost bah le
permaaphrost ne dégèle pas ni l'été ni
l'hiver moyen en quoi ça permet de
stabiliser l'usine et de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait une sécurité d'exploitation
je dis pas que c'est bien je dis voilà
le genre de solution qu'on met en œuvre
on préfère mettre ça en œuvre plutôt que
de se passer des énergies fossiles merci
beaucoup technosolutionniste et sobriété
les deux en même temps on va rappeler
les bons messages merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat Jean-Lou Ettine
Étienne vous avez préfacé l'ouvrage
Grand Nord un voyage dans le CERC
article qui est publié chez glena et
puis les monde polaire c'est le titre de
votre livre mikab du jour Mered au
presse universitaire de France je vous
dis à demain à 18h 22h sur Public Sénat
et notéz que l'invité de la matinale
demain Orian mansini reçoit le
porte-parole du rassemblement national
Laurent jacobelli le député RN de Mosel
bonne
soirée